That is true. It says for them to for
him to go and ask those who've been
reading the scripture before him
if he is in doubt about that which has
been revealed to him which is the Quran.
All right. So it says if you were in
doubt in what we have brought to you
down. So ask those that read the book
before you. It's a single book. Correct.
No, not necessarily.
Yes it. It's 100% necessary because can
can you pull up a verse in chapter 3
very quickly? is chapter 10 verse 94.
Yeah, you're talking about chapter 10
94. But I want to show you a verse in
chapter 3 in regards to Jesus here.
Okay.
Okay. With with the same with the same
terminology of the book. Okay. So God
says in chapter 3
of verse 48 if you have a chance.
I love that verse.
I love that verse too. It actually
proves a lot of Sunnis wrong in their
understanding of what the book is.
Okay.
This the one that talks about how he has
taught the wisdom and all that, right?
Yeah. It says uh and he will teach
Jesus. He will teach Jesus the book, the
wisdom, and then the Torah and the
gospel. So the Torah and the gospel,
okay, is a little different than what
the book and the wisdom is. And God
states in chapter 2 that he sends the
prophets, right? And brings down on them
the book so that they could judge
between what the people are differing.
So the message of the book is always
been the same. And all the prophets have
received the same book. What you're
talking about is the scriptures. Those
are trying to teach you if you're
willing to listen the book and the
wisdom.
Okay. So, so what I was trying to say is
quite very clearly that if someone reads
let's assume what the old testament or
the old testament and the new testament
because they have to go hand in hand
there's sufficient information for the
person there to know what they need to
do for that they are in a decent setting
on the day of judgment be kind to your
parents pray give from what you have
been given be a good human being uh uh
worship your lord with all your love uh
be call people towards your lord all of
this is present in both books and this
is what is you what's the duty upon you
as a human.
Okay.
What is the book that the people are of
when it calls us the people of the book?
What is that book?
The people of the book would even
include Sunnis and Shia. Nowadays the
people of the book are the people who
want to adhere to what God has said
within his book.
Yeah. But when Muhammad is okay. So when
Muhammad says in 568
say oh people of the book you have
nothing to stand on unless you stand on
the Torah gospel and all that's been
revealed to you
and what was been revealed to you. So
it's not just the Torah and the gospel
but it's true and the thing is
what what are they the book of what are
they the people what book are they the
people of
the book is whatever God has sent
already with the prophets. So this is
what what the book is telling you is the
judgments of God the wisdom. So God uses
the book and the wisdom. The book is the
judgments, what to do and what not to
do. The wisdom is the why you shouldn't
do it and why you should do it. So
whatever rules that God has already
ordained on humanity like don't steal,
don't cheat is present in both books. So
if you do uphold what the gospel is
telling you in regards to the rules, the
book and if you uphold what the Torah is
telling you, you're in good standings
with God.
This is where I'm This is where you're
losing me.
I know
you. So you talked about how the book is
separate from the Torah and the Gospel
and the Quran.
So it's its own thing, right?
Because Noah had the book as well, but
Noah did not have a written book at that
point. The book is what God has written
as rules.
Be slow for me.
Sorry.
So you have the book that is separate
from the Torah, the Gospel, the Quran.
Correct.
Okay.
this book, these people are reading it,
right?
No. Uh people read the gospel, the
Torah, the Psalms, and the Quran to
teach them the book.
In chapter 10 verse 94, it says, "So if
you are in doubt about that which we
have revealed to you,
then ask those who have been reading the
scripture or in your case what you're
saying the book before you."
So they are reading this book.
Yes. So reading the book, right, is like
me reading the thermometer. The word in
Arabic is like reading and deducing
information, right? When I read the
thermometer, I understand the
temperature. Okay. But just saying
there's an actual thermometer that
you're reading.
Correct. So the Torah, the go
here,
the Torah, the Gospel, and the Quran.
When you're reading them, you are
reading the singular book. That's what I
was trying to explain.
Yeah. What what book are they reading?
Because it says they're reading it. So
they have something in their hands
that's physical that they're reading.
Correct. So this would also apply to the
people who wrote the Torah, the people
who wrote uh write read the Gospels and
people who read the Psalms. And there's
other other religious books that this
applies to. So for example, Buddhist,
would this would the Torah, Gospel, and
Psalms be included when it says those uh
the book before you reading the book
before you that would include the Torah,
Gospel, and Psalms?
Correct. So that is true that it is
there for them to get a confirmation
does not give it authority because the
Quran as it says is to fix what they did
wrong in the book but the book as I
already told you the book is already
sufficient.
All right. So
going all the way back then,
we have just surmised that this that
this verse is telling them telling
Muhammad if he's in doubt about the
Quran
to go ask the people who
yeah the people who reading the book
before him.
So for example
you read you read the book before the
Quran correct?
One second. So this means this is the
Torah, the Gospel, and the Psalms that
they're reading.
And there's other books as well.
And he can go ask them in regards of the
Quran
and see if the Quran's lining up with
these what, right, with these books
and he'll know that he has no reason to
doubt the Quran. Correct.
It's Yes. For the him to realize that
God told him the truth.
Yes.
Right.
So,
but one minute. How is that giving that
authority over the Quran rather than
confirming the Quran?
Because if the Quran is not in line with
these books, then the Quran is false.
Okay?
If it is in line with these books, the
Quran is true.
But here is now here is now where I am
going to catch you because you have
explained your position and I made you
repeat your position. But I want you to
take two two verses above when God says
Because he's not talking about doubting
the book. He is asking. So, so God is
saying today we will rescue you in your
body so that you would be a sign for
those who are before you. And the
majority of the people are unaware of
the signs of God. This is about Pharaoh.
And then God discusses about the
children of Israel. Okay. That's
correct.
That Yes. And then God says that if you
are doubting what I told you then go ask
the people who are talking about Moses
and Pharaoh and see how I told you the
truth.
So
so it's not about wait a minute let me
let me is it talking
you just you just stopped man you got to
let me respond
I sorry I just want to knock it home. So
when God says that we want to confirm
he's not confirming the whole Quran.
He's forming he's confirming the story
in regards to Pharaoh and Moses. Do you
agree?
No I don't but let me go with you. I can
grant this position and show you how it
doesn't change anything. Let's agree
that for the sake of argument, it's only
referring to the stories about Pharaoh
and the Israelites and Moses that Allah
is sharing in this chapter. I mean, we
can even go further. He shares stories
of Noah earlier in chapter se in verse
70 and stuff like that. So he's talking
about all these stories about the
previous prophets and the Israelites and
their adventures, their exile, their
will, all it's talking about all of that
kind of stuff. Okay. Now let's say that
the Quran is only referring to these
stories that it just mentioned, right?
If Muhammad is in doubt about what Allah
is revealing to him in the Quran
regarding these stories, then he has to
go check the previous scripture
to make sure that the Quran is in line
with what the previous scripture says
regarding these stories. Right.
Again, you're trying to include other
stories when this is specifically about
the children of Moses.
No, you said Noah. You included Noah and
that's in the earlier chapters. I'm
sorry, not the chapters. That's in the
same chapter in the earlier verses.
Yes. But that then then this is where
your position is incorrect because it's
clearly saying to you just say Moses
then. Let's just say I'm I'm going show
you no matter how you do this, it's not
going to change nothing. So let's just
say just wait. No, let's just say just
Moses. Okay.
The story of Moses, the Israelites,
Pharaoh, and and the and the Exodus,
right? That's what it's talking about.
Him saving the Israelites from from
Pharaoh and stuff.
Okay. If Muhammad is doubting
the story that the Quran is revealing to
him in this context,
Allah says for him to go ask the people
who've been reading the scripture before
him. So for
maybe I can dumb it down for you.
No, it's already dumbed down enough. I
think that
No, no, no. I I think you're missing
something very significant. So if
someone comes to me,
notice how I listen to you.
Sure. Go ahead.
I let you hit your point home, right?
Sure. So, so work with me like I just
worked with you. Is that cool?
Yes. Sorry. You're all right. I don't
mean to be rude.
It's all good. So, if Muhammad's
doubting what Allah has revealed to him
in the Quran about these stories,
then he can go ask those who've been
reading the scripture before him and
he'll see that the Quran lines up with
what the the previous scriptures say.
Correct.
the Quran is lining up with this
specific story. Correct?
And so if once he sees that the Quran
lines up with this specific story in the
previous scripture, he'll know that the
Quran is telling the truth about this
story. Right.
Correct. That God said the same thing
twice.
All right. If Muhammad finds out when he
checks the previous scripture on this
story and he finds out that actually the
Quran does not line up with what the
previous scripture says then he'll know
that the Quran regarding the story is
false. Right?
Then it's not from God.
Very good. So, so the criteria or the
judge or authority on whether the Quran
is true or false regarding the story is
the previous scripture.
Right.
Correct. That has to confirm the one
before. True.
All right.
Okay. In this story, now question. If
someone comes tells me that Trump is an
is a is an abuser in the world, assume.
Okay. And then they told me, if you
don't believe me, go ask the Democrats.
And I go ask the Democrats and they tell
me the same thing. Does now now the
Democrats get to judge everything that
this man says, or is it in this specific
incident?
Well, if
are they in authority now over that man?
If you're if you make it clear and you
qualify what you're asking about and
telling them what to check, if you
qualify it, then particularly they are
an authority on what you qualified.
Perfect.
Unfortunately, the Quran doesn't qualify
it here.
No, it does
generalizes it.
No, it's not generalizing because the
word of God, right, is confirming the
word of God. But God as well in the
book, he is dispelling the word of man.
So when God is saying go look at what I
sent before, you will see that it's
there again with you. So that it would
give you support that you're not going
away from what I've already said. So for
examp we already got that part. The
problem that we're having is is you're
saying if you uh uh with your example
about the Democrats, are they in
authority over everything?
No.
In your example, you qualified what you
were telling them to check and what
but here God did.
No. Where where does he where does he
qualify what he's ask what he's telling
Muhammad to check out
what we have given you right he didn't
say the whole book at this point but
this is what
what was given to him
the fact that God is talking about
so God is telling you about the story of
Pharaoh and this is what God is bringing
to him right now
but that's not what it says though
it clearly says
all right so does it say does it say if
you are in doubt about what we're saying
about the story of Pharaoh then go check
the pre go ask the people who've been
reading the scripture before you
because this is this is literally how
the content in Arabic works. So this is
a paragraph. So when God So if I one
minute
so if I say to you like Trump is an evil
man and go ask the Democrats about what
I like what I'm revealing to you.
Is that now make it uh like authorative
on the whole thing said or it's about a
specific topic
right here it says so if you are in
doubt about that which we have revealed
to you. What was revealed to him?
Go back one line before and one line
before. That is literally what's being
revealed.
Okay. So there
is literally what's being revealed.
Okay. So that means that all the lines
prior to this is what's being revealed.
Correct.
Yes. In regards to the story paragraph.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. At first
it was what's what's prior to this? Now
you're And now it's Oh, regarding the
story that's prior to this. No, you
can't pick and choose, man. Which one is
it? Is it everything that comes prior to
this verse or is it just specifically
does he qualify? Well, actually, I'm
only talking about the story of Pharaoh.
Does he qualify that?
You know, honestly, even if we're
looking at the whole verses from the
beginning to the end, sure, you could
say that it's everything from that point
to end, which again, it still makes your
point moot.
Wait, wait, wait. Why from that point to
end? Why not? Because you're talking
what do you mean the suras before as
well?
Yeah, why not those too? Because now you
are taking away from what the Arabic is
saying because man
the Arabic does not
qualify.
It does qualify about which has which we
have revealed to you which is literally
what is happening right now.
Wait hold on. So this is 1094.
Yeah.
So we got 1093 and all the way to one.
We got surah 11. All of surah 11. Surah
9 8 76 543 2 and 1.
Correct.
All of that has been revealed prior to
94. Right.
Right. But there is something called
content. So if it's if God is talking
about everything that is in the Quran,
then the content will make it very
clear. For example,
where does he qualify? That's my
question.
Because it is not talking about the
Quran in general. It is specific to this
incident. Cuz for example,
where do you get that from?
I will give you an example from chapter
2. If you are in doubt in what we
brought down to our servant, right,
which is exactly there, then produce a
whole surah like it. So now he's talking
about the specificity which is a
chapter. He's not saying to you bring a
whole Quran like it. So it's very
specific.
That's not what he says.
It does. It says in chapter 2 if you
were in doubt.
All I'm asking for where does the verse
qualify that it's only talking about the
story of Pharaoh.
Avery, I'm giving you a very basic
lesson on how subject matter works in
Arabic. If I am reading this, it does
not mean the whole book, right? So I
will show you in chapter two when God is
saying
now it's
not helping me. Look, I
listen, it's not it's not lining up with
your bias where you're trying to give
us, right? You're Quranistan alone. We
don't use that term.
Okay? You're Quran alone. As far as my
my apologies, your Quran alone,
which means that you adhere to the
verses of the Quran.
Nobody's interpretation. None of that.
What I need besides a beat that's super
dumping is a verse that backs up what
you're saying.
Show me in the verse where it qualifies
that it's only talking about the story
of Pharaoh.
Sure.
I have it up on the screen if you want
me. I I got it on the screen. Here's the
verse on the right.
Where does it qualify that it's only
talking about the story of Pharaoh? Oh,
in this specific verse again, it's about
the content of the verse. It's it's very
clear when you're reading it in Arabic
that God is not talking about the whole
ent entirety of the book because God
when he's talking about the whole
entirety of the book, he will save the
book. If he's talking about the chapter,
he will save the chapter. But when God
and when we have revealed a chapter and
fighting has been prescribed in it, you
see him. So when and is just revelation,
it does not necessitate that it's the
whole revelation. It is what is being
revealed in the moment. That's how the
Arabic works.
I got you. So cool.
We can only see this in the Arabic,
ladies and gentlemen.
We can't context. We can't read it
plainly in the magical language of the
Arabic. That's where we will see and
read between the lines that Allah
actually qualifies. Well, when he says,
"If you're in doubt about what we
revealed to you," he really says in the
Arabic, "If you're in doubt about what
we have revealed specifically about the
story of Pharaoh, then go ask the people
who have been reading the scripture
before."
But but but sheh dilemma, I was just
under I was trying to wonder where does
it say what we have revealed to you
means the Quran at that point.
That's it. That's it.
No. So, so, so you're you have the
authority in the Arabic to tell me what
has been revealed to you as the Quran.
That's fine. Have a nice day.
The only thing I ask you to do is just
read and quote. If you can't do that,
you reach your end.
So dem the Democratics are the
authorities of Trump.
All